we've been addicted to catching battling
breeding and caring for pokemon for more
than 25 years with the launch of pokemon
legends arceus we decided to go back and
chart the history of the mainline
pokemon games going by their japanese
release dates this is the history of
pokemon
[Music]
as a child pokemon creator satoshi
tajiri collected and studied bugs
adorably the other kids even called him
dr bug as he grew up his love of bugs
was overtaken by a new love for video
games disappointed in the gaming
magazines on sale he decided to just
make his own stapling together
handwritten pages of reviews tips and
tricks the magazine was called game
freak and artist ken sugimori came on
board after seeing it for sale in a
store however tajiri was becoming
frustrated not at the magazine but at
the games themselves
he thought that they weren't good enough
and that he could do better inspired by
his love of collecting bugs as a child
in the early 90s he decided to create a
game based on catching collecting and
battling creatures game freak was
getting into the development business to
make a game called pokemon
ken sugimori was tasked with creating
the first batch of pokemon while tajiri
and a small team of programmers worked
on the mechanics the game took 6 years
to make and for a few of those years
tajiri would sleep for 12 hours then
work for 24 hours straight just to get
the game done game freak as a company
was constantly in financial trouble only
saved when another company called
creature inc invested in it tajiri
originally wanted to make pokemon for
the game boy because the game link cable
could be used to trade them legendary
nintendo developer shigeru miyamoto who
also served as producer on the game
suggested making two versions of pokemon
with different creatures on each further
encouraging trading on top of collecting
all the pokemon players existing in the
pokemon universe as trainers had to
collect eight badges from gym leaders
before defeating the elite four to
complete the game the pokemon themselves
were cute and tajiri wanted players to
be able to name them in order to feel a
closer connection but if you didn't want
to do that their regular names were
essentially adorable puns anyway like
pikachu pika being a japanese way to say
spark and chew being the sound a mouse
makes hence pikachu the electric mouse
tajiri didn't want to make a violent
video game so if pokemon lose a fight
they simply faint until they can be
revived at a pokemon center
pokemon red and green launched in japan
in february 1996 with blue releasing a
few months later as an exclusive to
subscribers of korokoro comic
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
despite launching at the end of the game
boys life cycle when everyone was
focusing on shiny new 3d games pokemon
became a hit
spurred on by trading people buying
multiple versions to collect them all
and rumors of how to obtain a mysterious
hidden pokemon called mew pokemon pick
up steam not long after the pokemon
manga and anime were released as well as
the trading cards and it exploded in
popularity
[Music]
the pokemon anime was incredibly popular
and pikachu main character ash's
companion pokemon quickly became a fan
favorite so much so in fact that game
freak launched pokemon yellow version
special pikachu edition aka pokemon
yellow in 1998
[Music]
[Applause]
it tied in closely with the anime
featuring characters from the show who
previously hadn't appeared in the games
it also updated the look of characters
like misty to closer match the show the
story and gameplay were mostly the same
as red and blue the biggest difference
was that you no longer chose between
bulbasaur charmander and squirtle as
your starting pokemon instead you were
given pikachu who would follow you
around the overworld pikachu had a
distinct personality and their opinion
of you would change throughout the game
while walking you could turn around and
check in on them
the following year pokemon gold and
silver were released for the game boy
color ushering in the second generation
of the series the games collectively
added a hundred new pokemon while still
including the original 151 and once
again the games required trading to
collect them all gen 2 also introduced
the new johto region but players were
still able to travel to kanto after
beating the elite four satoru uwata who
would later go on to become president of
nintendo worked on gold and silver and
developed key compression software for
the games along with new pokemon types
the ability to breed pokemon and
adjustments to how certain stats worked
the biggest change to gameplay came with
the introduction of the pokey gear an
all-in-one device that acted as your
radio map mobile phone calendar and
clock as well as adding a day night
cycle that affected in-game events and
when pokemon would spawn shiny pokemon
regular pokemon but with different
coloring also made their debut what was
exceptionally cool about gold and silver
was that not only could you trade
between gold and silver versions of the
game but you could also trade with red
blue and yellow there were limits on
this however you could only trade the
original 151 between the two generations
of the series but it was a really cool
indication of how pokemon wanted players
to build their collections and keep them
throughout generations
in 2000 an enhanced version of pokemon
gold and silver was released under the
name pokemon crystal there were tweaks
to gameplay and story but for the first
time ever you could choose to play as a
female character another major addition
was the battle tower where players
registered their pokemon and worked
their way up the tower by battling
others the game was rather infamously
bootlegged and its poor translations
eventually became huge memes in the
pokemon community i definitely recommend
checking out a playthrough on youtube if
you want to
go to the elf's world
[Music]
[Music]
pokemon ruby and sapphire kicked off gen
3 of pokemon games and launched on game
boy advance in late 2002 in japan the
major change was the addition of double
battles where you could send not one but
two of your pokemon out to fight coupled
with pokemon now having natures and
abilities that affect how they play
battling was more strategic than ever
but if you wanted to just kick back and
compete in a less stressful environment
pokemon could be entered into contests a
sort of crufts for your pocket monster
pals alongside the main games you could
buy pokemon box for the gamecube which
would allow you to store and organize up
to 1500 pokemon provided you had the
cable to hook up the two systems ruby
and sapphire were the first games
directed by yunichi masuda a longtime
pokemon developer who had acted as a
composer game designer and co-director
on previous games he would later go on
to direct most of the mainline pokemon
titles in 2004 remakes of the original
red and green called fire red and leaf
green launched on game boy advance the
biggest selling point beyond being a
color version of the games many grew up
with was that pokemon could now be
traded wirelessly and provided you
traded enough you could have every
pokemon ever released in one game the
game also included new islands to
explore which were not in the original
red and green versions as well as the
union room where up to 30 players could
hang out and battle also in 2004 an
enhanced version of pokemon ruby and
sapphire was released with the name
pokemon emeralds along with typical
tweaks the main change came to the story
in pokemon ruby the bad guys were team
magma who were trying to use a legendary
pokemon to increase the world's land
mass in sapphire you fought against team
aqua who wanted to expand the seas in
emerald you're trying to stop both of
the teams with the aid of a different
legendary pokemon
2006's pokemon diamond and pearl not
only kicked off gen 4 in pokemon but
also took us to sinnoh a brand new more
3d region filled with over a hundred new
pokemon the day night cycle from gold
and silver returned and added more time
periods to the day the biggest additions
came thanks to the nintendo ds its
second screen acted as your poke which
was like a beefed up poke gear allowing
you to obtain new apps like a pedometer
or a memo pad the game also utilized the
ds's wi-fi systems players could hang
out with others and make their own bases
in the underground an area beneath
sinnoh as well as use voice chat to talk
to each other the enhanced version of
diamond and pearl pokemon platinum
expanded upon the wi-fi functionality
and introduced the distortion world a
new parallel world where down was up and
up was down with the aim of tackling the
legendary pokemon giratina at the end
heart gold and soul silver are remakes
of you guessed it gold and silver but
added functionality for the ds
touchscreen including touch controls and
pokeathon mini games similarly to
pokemon yellow a pokemon would follow
you around the overworld provided it was
listed as first in your party when
walking with you the pokemon can even
occasionally find items the game also
came bundled with a pokewalker a
pedometer that you could load a pokemon
into it would then gain experience
depending on how much you walked
kicking off the fifth generation of
pokemon was 2010s black and white and
the addition of over a hundred more
pokemon as well as seasons previous
games had a day night cycle and various
time periods throughout the in-game day
but now certain areas and pokemon could
only be found during specific seasons
double battles were old news so black
and white introduced not only triple
battles but rotation battles where
pokemon took turns fighting in a
rotating circle the game's graphics also
got a significant bump not only was the
game world 3d but during battle the
pokemon themselves were now more
animated complete with a highlight
camera for dramatic moments
set two years after black and white
black 2 and white 2 took the place of
the typical enhanced version instead of
releasing pokemon grey the game freak
team wanted to pleasantly surprise
players with two sequels with yunichi
masuda revealing that there were game
mechanics that necessitated two games
instead of the standard one pokestar
studios is an area in the game that
allows players to make films of their
pokemon which are then ranked based on
how much they rake in at the box office
pokemon world tournament was also added
a way for players to battle against
trainers from previous pokemon games if
you wanted to face off against brock but
use a gen 5 pokemon to knock him on his
ass this was for you
[Music]
2013's x and y was a huge leap for
pokemon if black and white were edging
the mainline franchise closer to 3d then
x and y fully committed the leap was
huge and it took place in a wildly new
location kalos which was inspired by
france in terms of gameplay a brand new
pokemon type was added for the first
time in almost 10 years the fairy type
battles and training saw significant
changes fights were no longer confined
to the ground if you were battling
flying pokemon they could duke it out in
the air your pokemon could also battle
against up to five wild pokemon the
biggest of all the new additions was the
mega evolution which would see temporary
huge changes to the certain pokemon that
could do it your pokemon could now
undergo super training to level up base
stats rather than its level but if you
wanted to just simply care for your
pokemon and build your bond pokemon and
me would allow you to play mini games
pet and feed your pokemon building your
bond would impact battle success pokemon
would gain more xp withstand stronger
attacks or even land more critical hits
x and y were also widely praised for
their online system with the player
search system offering new ways to meet
battle and trade with others more easily
in 2014 gba games ruby and sapphire were
remade for the 3ds the games saw quite a
drastic overhaul with many modern
elements incorporated from later games
such as 3d mega evolutions the new fairy
type super training pokemon me and over
100 tms in comparison to the 50 the game
originally shipped with the game had new
characters added and new mechanics like
the pokenav plus to take advantage of
the 3ds's second screen omega ruby and
alpha sapphire were huge upgrades to the
original games x and y took us to france
so sun and moon took us to the
hawaii-inspired alola region some
pokemon had alolan forms and therefore
looked different other common terms were
renamed for the new location gyms became
island trials a number of puzzles and
battles ending in a battle with the
island kahuna and the battle tower was
the battle tree z moves were introduced
as a strong pokemon move that's only
able to be used once per battle and in
classic pokemon style enhanced versions
of the generation 7 games followed
shortly after with ultra sun and ultra
moon introducing new alolan forms of
pokemon as well as some story changes
and extra challenges and even
collectibles the game also introduced
ultra beasts who would emerge from an
ultra wormhole you could also travel
into the wormhole to ultra space to find
legendary pokemon from older games like
mewtwo
2018 saw the first mainline pokemon
release on nintendo switch with let's go
eevee and pikachu which were remakes of
pokemon yellow but now not only were
they in full color they were 3d and the
control scheme was much easier to use in
fact you only needed one joy-con or the
pokeball plus accessory taking
inspiration from the wildly popular
pokemon mobile game pokemon go let's go
let you use motion controls to aim and
throw pokeballs to catch new pokemon you
could also bring over pokemon from
pokemon go with over 800 pokemon
released let's go decided to pair back
to only the original 151 plus a new
legendary it was easier than ever to
track down and battle just the ones you
need for your pokedex as pokemon would
freely wander in the overworld and the
top member of your team would wander
along with you the whole time
sword and shield set in the british
inspired galar region launched for
switch the following year mixing classic
pokemon gameplay with a lot of the
changes that let's go made new additions
included the wild area a huge open space
filled with pokemon to catch but one of
the biggest no pun intended additions
was dynamaxing and giganta maxing where
mid-battle pokemon could become massive
and increase their power you could
assign your pokemon a job and they might
even get you items or you could set up
camp and just hang out with your pokemon
or even invite some friends from online
to join you for some curry however there
was some controversy in a move dubbed
exit not all previously available
pokemon were available in sword and
shield game freak revealed that this was
for balancing reasons as well as because
it would be a huge amount of work to
create all the character models in the
new game sword and shield had two
expansions called the isle of armor and
the crown tundra and they added a lot
more pokemon to the games in those
2021 saw 3d remakes of diamond and pearl
with added quality of life changes and a
chibi art style it was developed by ilca
making it the first game in the mainline
series not to be developed by game freak
but yunichi masuda was the co-director
on the project this brings us to pokemon
legends archaeos a game that takes place
in the sinnoh region but many
many years ago when it was called the
hisui region that means no pokemon
league and no concept of even being a
pokemon trainer your task is actually to
make the first ever pokedex for the
region so there you have it the history
of the mainline pokemon series for more
on legends archaeos make sure to stick
around right here on gamespot we'll link
some videos for you including things
that you may not know about pokemon for
more deep dives into your favorite game
series make sure to subscribe thanks for
watching
[Music]